>> Laura: RESISTING GLOBALISM
AND WINNING.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
IT’S OFTEN LOST IN THE
COHEN-COMEY-MUELLER SHUFFLE,
MORE IMPORTANT ISSUE, FAR MORE
IMPORTANT WITH A FAR GREATER
IMPACT AND REACH.
THE THREAT OF GLOBALISM.
WERE IT NOT FOR THE LEADERSHIP
VISION AND HARD WORK OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, WE COULD
BE LOOKING AT A MUCH LESS FREE
AND PROSPEROUS USA OVER THE NEXT
100 YEARS.
THE PRESIDENTS INSTINCTS PUSHING
FOR A BORDER WALL, RENEGOTIATING
FOR A BORDER WALL, RENEGOTIATINA
FOR A BORDER WALL, RENEGOTIATINT
FOR A BORDER WALL, RENEGOTIATINO
FOR A BORDER WALL, RENEGOTIATIN,
FOR A BORDER WALL, RENEGOTIATINI
FOR A BORDER WALL, RENEGOTIATINS
FOR A BORDER WALL, RENEGOTIATING
ON FAIR TRADE WITH CHINA, ARE
SPOT ON.
>> AMERICA WILL ALWAYS CHOOSE
INDEPENDENCE AND COOPERATION
OVER GLOBAL GOVERNANCE, CONTROL
AND DOMINATION.
I HONOR THE RIGHT OF EVERY
NATION IN THIS ROOM TO PURSUE
ITS OWN CUSTOMS, BELIEFS, AND
TRADITIONS.
THE UNITED STATES WILL NOT TELL
YOU HOW TO LIVE OR WORK OR
WORSHIP.
WE ONLY ASK THAT YOU HONOR OUR
SOVEREIGNTY IN RETURN.
>> Laura: ON MOST EVERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE, TRUMP HAS HELD
FIRM, EVEN IN THE FACE OF
IMMENSE RESISTANCE FROM THOSE
WHO HAVE MADE BILLIONS ON THE
FAILED PROMISE OF GLOBALISM.
>> AMERICA IS GOVERNED BY
AMERICANS.
WE REJECT THE IDEOLOGY OF
GLOBALISM, AND WE EMBRACE THE
DOCTRINE OF PATRIOTISM.
>> Laura: BUT THE PRESIDENT
HAS FACED ENORMOUS OPPOSITION IN
HIS EFFORTS, AND NOT JUST FROM
OUTSIDE HIS OWN PARTY.
THIS WAS HIS FORMER DIRECTOR OF
THE NATIONAL ECONOMIC COUNCIL,
GARY COHN, THIS MORNING.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT OFFENDED BY
THE TERM GLOBALIST BECAUSE I AM
A GLOBALIST.
I BELIEVE WE LIVE IN A
GLOBALIZED WORLD.
I THINK THE UNITED STATES IS A
VERY INTEGRAL PART OF A
GLOBALIZED WORLD.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
LIVE AS A GOOD CITIZEN.
SO DO THE CHINESE.
SO DO THE RUSSIANS.
SORT OF THE MIDDLE EASTERN
COUNTRIES.
BUT WE ARE GLOBALIZED.
WE CANNOT CHANGE THAT BACK.
>> Laura: WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO BE GOOD GLOBAL
CITIZENS?
THAT MIGHT SOUND REALLY
HIGH-MINDED.
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE 20 YEARS
SINCE CHINA ENTERED THE WTO IS
NOT PRETTY.
WE ENDED UP ENRICHING OTHER
COUNTRIES AND LOTS OF LOST
TRADERS LIKE GARY COHN HIMSELF
AS OUR OWN MIDDLE-CLASS SUFFERED
AS OUR OWN MIDDLE-CLASS SUFFERE.
THOUSANDS OF U.S. COMPANIES
MOVED OVERSEAS FOR CHEAPER
PRODUCTION, ALL USHERED IN UNDER
THE BANNER OF GLOBALIZATION.
GONE WERE MOST AMERICAN-MADE
PRODUCTS, TEXTILES, TOYS,
TELEVISIONS.
IT SURE WASN’T WHAT THE
GLOBALIST TOLD US WHAT HAPPENED
ONCE CHINA WAS WELCOMED INTO THE
WORLD TRADE COMMUNITY.
>> BY JOINING THE WTO, CHINA IS
NOT SIMPLY AGREEING TO IMPORT
MORE OF OUR PRODUCTS.
IT IS AGREEING TO IMPART ONE OF
DEMOCRACY’S MOST CHERISHED
VALUES: ECONOMIC FREEDOM.
THE MORE CHINA LIBERALIZED ITS
ECONOMY, THE MORE FULLY IT WILL
LIBERATE THE POTENTIAL OF ITS
PEOPLE.
THEIR INITIATIVE, THEIR
IMAGINATION, AND THEIR
REMARKABLE SPIRIT OF ENTERPRISE.
>> Laura: WELL, HOW DID THAT
WORK OUT?
SURE THE CHINESE ARE RICHER BUT
WE HAVE A $375 BILLION ANNUAL
TRADE DEFICIT WITH CHINA, AND
THE ONLY IMAGINATION THEY
BROUGHT TO THE GAME IS IN THERE
PLOTTING TO STEAL AMERICA’S
INNOVATION.
18 YEARS AFTER CHINA’S ENTRANCE
INTO THE WTO, EVEN TRUMP’S MOST
ARDENT CRITICS ARE CONCEDING
THAT BASICALLY HE’S RIGHT.
>> LET’S BE HONEST.
ON ONE BIG FUNDAMENTAL POINT,
DONALD TRUMP IS RIGHT.
CHINA IS A TRADE CHEAT.
THE U.S. TRADE REPRESENTATIVE’S
THE REPORT TO CONGRESS ON
CHINA’S COMPLIANCE WITH GLOBAL
TRADING RULES IS AN EXCEPTIONAL
WORTH READING.
IT LAYS OUT THE MANY WAYS CHINA
HAS FAILED TO ENACT PROMISED
ECONOMIC REFORMS, BACKTRACKED ON
OTHERS, AND USED FORMAL AND
INFORMAL MEANS FROM BLOCKING
FIRMS FROM COMPETING IN CHINA’S
MARKET.
ALL CONTRADICTS BEIJING’S
COMMITMENTS WHEN IT JOINED THE
WTO IN 2001.
>> Laura: BINGO.
EVEN AS THE INTELLIGENTSIA BEGIN
TO RECOGNIZE REALITY, SOME
LIBERAL DO-GOODERS IN HOLLYWOOD
AND SILICON VALLEY ARE M.I.A.
THEY ARE WILLING TO BOW TO THE
CHINESE SENSORS TO MAINTAIN
ACCESS TO THE MARKETPLACE.
DESPERATE TO CAPTURE THE CHINESE
BOX OFFICE, INDUSTRY EXECS FORGO
ANY PROJECT THAT WOULD OFFEND
THEIR CHINESE OVERLORDS.
WHERE IS THAT MAO FILM,
MR. SPIELBERG.
REDESIGNED, EDITED.
ALL TO PLEASE THEIR COMMUNIST
BUSINESS PARTNERS.
THE HOLLYWOOD CROWD CLAIMS TO BE
VIGILANT GUARDIANS OF ARTISTIC
EXPRESSION THEY GIVE TEDIOUS
SPEECH IS THAT AWARDS SHOW ABOUT
LIVING YOUR TRUTH.
THEY AVOID THE INCONVENIENT
TRUTH ABOUT HOW DAY IN AND DAY
OUT, CHINA BURGLARIZES
DISSIDENTS BOTH RELIGIOUS AND
POLITICAL.
THE AP IS REPORTING THAT A
MILLION MUSLIMS ARE HOUSED IN
INTERNMENT CAMPS IN CHINA.
ONE FACILITY, THEY ARE FORCED TO
MAKE CLOTHING THAT DESPITE BEING
MAKE CLOTHING THAT DESPITE BEINGA VIOLATION OF U.S. LAW HAS MADE
A VIOLATION OF U.S. LAW HAS MADE
ITS WAY TO AMERICAN SPORTSWEAR
SUPPLIER.
AND IT’S CHRISTMAS SEASON.
I ASK YOU TO REMEMBER WHAT’S
HAPPENING TO CHINA’S ESTIMATED
100 MILLION CHRISTIANS.
HOUSE CHURCH PASTORS AND
UNDERGROUND BISHOPS ARE ARRESTED
UNDERGROUND BISHOPS ARE ARRESTE
ARRESTED.
CHURCHES ARE BULLDOZED.
CROSSES RIPPED OFF STEEPLES.
PARISHIONERS ARE FORCED TO
CELEBRATE IN SECRET.
AND THERE ARE REPORTS THAT THE
REGIME HAS OBJECTED LONG GONE
MEMBERS TO FORCED ORGAN
HARVESTING.
THE KHASHOGGI MURDER BY THE
SAUDIS IS STILL MAKING NEWS AND
TRUMPETS FAULTED FOR HIS
RESPONSE.
BUT THERE IS NO EQUIVALENT MEDIA
COVERAGE OR CONDEMNATION OF
CHINA FOR ITS WIDESPREAD ONGOING
HORRIFIC HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATION.
HORRIFIC HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATION.ACCESS TO THE CHINESE MARKET HAS
ACCESS TO THE CHINESE MARKET HASTURNED CAPTAINS OF INDUSTRY INTO
TURNED CAPTAINS OF INDUSTRY INTO
SILENT STOOGES, AND FRANKLY,
ENABLERS.
>> THE CHINESE COMPANIES HAVE
BEEN WORKING TOGETHER FOR MANY
YEARS TO DRIVE NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
A LOT OF GROWTH IN QUALCOMM’S
BUSINESS HAS COME FROM WORKING
WITH CHINESE COMPANIES.
>> THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT AND
CHINESE PARTNERS UNDERSTAND THAT
WE ARE A VALUABLE PARTNER IN
UPGRADING THE INDUSTRIES.
WE CAN SEE THAT CHINA IS
BECOMING MUCH MORE POSITIVE
TOWARD INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
PROTECTION.
>> Laura: WE WILL SEE THAT
WHEN WE BELIEVE IT.
THE POLITICAL CLASS IS AFRAID OF
GOLDMAN SACHS, HEDGE FUNDS, AND
ANY BIG BUSINESS THAT STUPIDLY
STAKES SO MUCH OF ITS FUTURE ON
A COMMUNIST COUNTRY.
SO THE GLOBALIST DON’T REALLY
RESIST CHINA.
THEY RESIST TRUMP AND ARE
FIGHTING THE PRESIDENT, URGING
HIM TO BACK OFF HIS TOUGH TRADE
POLICIES WITH CHINA.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE
ARITHMETIC, CHINESE EXPORTS TO
THE UNITED STATES, U.S. TO
CHINA, AND WHAT THE IMPACT OF
TERRACES, AGAIN, IT DRIVES
THINGS IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
>> I THINK IN THE LONG TERM,
IT’S BAD FOR AMERICAN
MANUFACTURING.
>> THE WAY IT’S BEING DONE RIGHT
NOW IS NOT HAVING A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON THE BUSINESSES THAT
COULD POTENTIALLY IMPACT THE
WORKERS.
>> Laura: THESE ARE MANY OF
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO FOUGHT HIM
ON NAFTA AND ARE OBJECTING TO A
BORDER WALL.
ISN’T IT FUNNY HOW IT WORKS?
IT’S LIKE A VENN DIAGRAM.
FOR THE MOMENT, THE PRESIDENT
STANDING FIRM.
>> SINCE THEY JOINED THE WTO, WE
HAVE RACKED UP $4.5 TRILLION IN
TRADE DEFICITS WITH CHINA.
YEAR AFTER YEAR, POLITICIANS RAN
FOR OFFICE PROMISING TO FIX OUR
HORRIBLE TRADE DEALS.
AND I TOOK IT ON AND THAT’S
RIGHT.
WHEN THEY CHARGE US AGE HERE OF,
WE CHARGE THEM A TARIFF NOW.
OKAY?
I DON’T BLAME THESE OTHER
COUNTRIES.
I BLAME OUR PAST LEADERSHIP FOR
ALLOWING THESE OTHER COUNTRIES
TO GET AWAY WITH IT.
>> Laura: NOW THEY HAVE A 90
DAY COOLING OFF PERIOD BUT HE
SHOULD NOT RELENT.
WHY SHOULDN’T HE RELENT?
TARIFFS ARE WORKING.
THIS FROM THE HILL TODAY.
TARIFFS HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO
GROWTH DIRECTLY AND INDIRECTLY
IN THE FOUR MAIN AREAS WHERE
TARIFFS WERE IMPOSED.
STEEL, ALUMINUM, SOLAR PANELS
AND WASHING MACHINES.
THAN 11,000 JOBS AS OF AUGUST.
THE U.S. HAS DIRECTLY ADDED MORE
SINCE THEN, MORE INVESTMENTS AND
JOBS HAVE BEEN ANNOUNCED
INCLUDING A MASSIVE $1.5 BILLION
STEEL PLANT BY STEEL DYNAMICS
THAT WILL EMPLOY SOME 600
WORKERS.
IN THE SOLAR ARENA, SOLAR POWER
WORLD MAGAZINE LESS MORE THAN A
DOZEN U.S. COMPANIES FOR NEW
FACILITIES HAVE BEEN STARTED
AND/OR EXPANDED.
GOOD STUFF.
ONLY THE UNITED STATES MY
FRIENDS HAS THE ECONOMIC AND
MORAL MIGHT TO KEEP CHINA’S
GLOBAL AMBITIONS IN CHECK.
AS PRESIDENT SHE CONTINUES HIS
RUTHLESS CONSOLIDATION OF POWER
ALONG WITH AGGRESSIVE GLOBAL
EXPANSION, BOTH PARTIES NEED TO
CONSIDER THIS QUESTION.
WILL YOU SUPPORT POLICIES THAT
STRENGTHEN THE HAND OF A
MURDEROUS COMMUNIST REGIME IN
CHINA?